those origin wounds they do cut deep
these are things that actually change
the trajectory of our lives and so when
we go back to those moments and we
actually witness the little Vienna in
this case right who was The Observer and
the witnesser of a tremendous amount of
conflict and gaslighting and
manipulation and paranoia and abuse
through my parents divorce right like oh
and I get to witness her and what it was
like for this little human who had no
other siblings who didn't have any other
adults around to help her process this
right then I start to connect with you
know the part of me that that didn't
feel emotionally safe when you can start
to connect to that to grieve alongside
of it I always say like when in doubt
grieve more you know it's like when
stuck grieve more like anything grieve
more